a second missile field capable of
housing nuclear missiles that could
reach the u.s
has just been discovered in china lucas
tomlinson at the pentagon shows us the
evidence and gets official reaction
to that discovery tonight for the second
time in two months
new satellite photos show china building
over a hundred silos to house nuclear
missiles
when complete it will have more than two
hundred that's half the number of
land-based silos the u.s military has
in the western united states silos are
great for
is soaking up enemy warheads
if you look at china's silos which now
are on the kind of order of 240
it takes at least two nuclear warheads
to destroy each silo
jeffrey lewis an expert on china's
nuclear arsenal is part of a team that
discovered the first missile site in
june
he says when operational chinese
missiles carrying multiple nuclear
warheads
can reach targets over 9 000 miles away
putting all of the united states in
range
the head of u.s forces in the pacific is
also sounding the alarm
china is coming at us rapidly
that includes economically
diplomatically and militarily
the state department also taking note of
china's rapidly growing nuclear arsenal
quote
beijing has sharply deviated from its
decades-old nuclear strategy
based on minimum deterrence in its
annual report to congress on china the
pentagon warned
over the next decade china's nuclear
warhead stockpile
currently estimated to be in the low
200s is projected to at least
double in size as china expands and
modernizes
its nuclear forces the u.s has more than
5 000 nuclear warheads
china and the united states have no
nuclear arms control treaties
i think very important that we find a
way
to at least talk about how we want to
manage this hostility
so that you know we don't end up in a
nuclear war
early next month the pentagon is
expected to release its new annual
report
detailing china's military expansion
including its nukes
brett lucas thomason at the pentagon
lucas thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else